today's the last day of the end zone
where we looked at hand Sultan's famous
ontological argument last class well
that was a week ago so I want to do a
little bit of reviewing just to keep
things fresh in your mind because I'm
guessing you know first time that you're
exposed to the material you probably
didn't retain that much of it and if we
go back to it we make connections and
retain more of it so the first thing I
actually want to do is have all of you
vote about something everybody has to
vote you know otherwise it doesn't work
so you have to raise your hands for for
one of these it could have been while
you were in the class session maybe
haven't thought about it again so his
argument since we last talked about in
the class but you did think about it you
did have it you know in the
understanding as was he on some website
so there's three options what does
Anselm's argument is convincing for me I
think he did in fact prove that God
exists with his particular argument so
you could believe that that God exists
when you come in the class and then say
yeah but anseong has a good proof for it
I suppose if you didn't believe that God
exists and you and now you think that
Anselm had a good proof for it you're
kind of stuck you now we have to believe
that God exists right or you might say
the Anselm's argument must be wrong
we've got to be something wrong with
this maybe you know what that is you
know maybe you're like a manual contour
Thomas Aquinas odds are you're not and
you just have some sort of vague sense
that something like a magic trick took
place here I don't know where exactly
the rabbit got stuck in the Hat but I
think somebody put a rabbit in that hat
before they they pulled it out the third
one third possibility is ants on Mazama
solving I think he is I'm not convinced
by the arguments but I think there's
something going on there
I can't quite put my finger on what it
is so I want you to vote on each one and
we'll actually start out in the middle
how many of you think Anselm's argument
it's got to be wrong and if you're if
you're actually you know like a
committed atheist yeah
that cancels arguments wrong because
otherwise we prove that God exists right
how many people think it's gonna be
wrong one nobody else thinks he's gotta
be wrong - okay three okay so how many
think the Anselm's argument if you found
it convincing and in some you may not
have understood the whole thing one two
three four or five okay
how many think that he's on something
and you're not quite sure what it is but
you're sure it must be something more
going on - that's kind of interesting
you notice that a lot of people I mean
you could say well they're just
indifferent or something like that work
how they didn't vote yet so they had to
find some way to vote I think if that's
really your because you have you know
red ants on a lot you haven't clawed a
lot about these sort of things I'm
guessing that you didn't do much reading
of great theological thinkers in high
school right because we don't do that
sort of thing in high school except in
certain schools if you in fact thought
that ant song is onto something and you
have some idea of what it is or you have
no clue as to what it is what we're
going to do today well we'll fill it in
and we're not actually going to talk
about whether God exists we we handled
that with religion 2 to 4 so you know
that those are those are the chapters
where he's talking about God's existence
now we're not looking at God's existence
we're looking at God's attributes so if
you you know if you come into New York
committed atheist you think God doesn't
exist then look at this is sort of a
mapley what if God did exist what would
he have to have or what would did have
to have what kind of attributes what
would those attributes be like you know
when we say things like God is merciful
do we mean that God is merciful
that human beings are merciful that's a
big problem that's a problem in what we
call the philosophy of religion but also
the philosophy of language because we
have these terms like merciful or just
or powerful or mighty or all-knowing all
these sorts of things or even terms like
light you notice handsome talks about
God is being light does that mean that
he's light like these lights up here
turn God on and off break the circuit
activate the circuit it can't mean that
sort of thing to me and gods like a
candle a big big candle that doesn't
make much sense either so there's got to
be something else going on there and we
have to dig in in order to figure out
what's going on there and you're gonna
see that and some is actually going to
get themselves to a point where he says
this is about as far as we can go we
can't really make this completely
understandable through the comprehensive
so it may not be satisfying to everybody
but we're gonna we're gonna explore it
and you notice when it comes to you know
it's got to be wrong or I find a
convincing that's about half and half
right we take out all the people who
think no some people find it convincing
so people don't about the same
proportion and that's the way it's been
every time that I've taught this
material and if you feel that Anselm's
argument is convincing you're in good
philosophical company because Hegel
thought it was convincing and Rene
Descartes who we're going to be reading
thought it was convincing if you think
that it's totally unconvincing you're
also in good philosophical company
because the manual can't we're going to
read systems totally you know
erroneous its fallacious and as a matter
of fact it's the the type of argument
that all the other arguments about God's
existence are based on they're all bad
different philosophers have different
signs for this so whichever side you
picked you
before we go into this stuff let's let's
think about a key difference what was
the term that has some use to try to
prove that God must exist that then
which nothing greater can be thought and
you notice he doesn't say something like
God is the supreme being he does think
that God is a Supreme Being but he
doesn't use that in his argument let's
say we think about his argument again
you ran along these sort of lines so
you've got somebody who says God doesn't
exist right we did Anselm called in the
biblical fool the fool says in his heart
there is no God now saying it at his
heart means that he has some sort of
conception in his mind about what we
mean by God and it could be God as the
Supreme Being or it could be God as that
guy in the sky with you know white robes
and a long beard and whose ABS people or
it could be that damn which nothing
greater can be thought those are all
possibilities it could be the savior of
Israel it could be these are all
concepts of God so let's say you start
out with God is that that which nothing
greater can be thought you've gathered
in your mind you say yeah there's
something like that of my mind but that
doesn't exist in reality that's not out
there that's only in here sort of like a
unicorn right unicorns exist what do you
think empathy post yourself time on
little girls closet doors they must
exist somewhere right
often they have English too right there
they're not just you know grunts and
Pegasus unicorns well you're right they
don't exist sometimes we have cartoons
or like the last unicorn gets killed for
us it's tasty you know
but that's imaginary so what the fool is
saying is God is imaginary I can have an
idea of God but there's no such stuff
now if you have an idea of God as the
Supreme Being that's not going to get
you from the idea of God up to God being
reality you got a suit God in reality
and then you get the idea of God's will
secrete v8 but if you start out with God
as the app that much nothing greater
could've thought they say that doesn't
exist in reality than what you're
actually doing is you're you're thinking
of something greater than that damn much
nothing greater can be because to exist
in reality excuse me is greater than to
only exist in the in the mind and
therefore there's a contradiction you
remember this this logic right if
there's a contradiction we have to get
rid of one of our assumptions and the
assumption that we get rid of is there
is no God
this is where it looks like pulling a
rabbit out of the Hat right it looks
like something hinky must have gone on
there somewhere along the line what a
lot of the river is is that can only
work if you use this term it doesn't
work if you use the supreme da you can
say okay God is the supreme being again
I'm the biblical fool right I don't
believe there's a guy okay you've got
this idea of a Supreme Being in your
head then can do anything you want super
powerful sees everything that I'm doing
kind of like you know hopped up Santa
Claus alright and like Santa Claus
bursting anybody's bubble here doesn't
exist although you know we do have shows
about Santa Claus when we talk about
Santa Claus and we you know tell the
little children that Santa Claus exists
you know later on and they start
figuring things out
exist in our hearts but that's not the
existing reality is it so I'm the
biblical fool what I'm saying yeah
Supreme Being that's what you call God
doesn't exist I have an idea of it
because I know exactly what I'm
rejecting on your part you have an idea
of it because you think it actually
exists out here in reality and now you
try to do the same sequence well you
know would you grant that it's greater
to exist in reality than to just exist
in life sure that's exactly why I don't
think you're your God exists
is what the biblical fool would say
right and then you say well aren't you
thinking of something greater than the
Supreme Being them and thinking of a God
that would actually exist in reality
okay you have as many attributes to the
Supreme Being as you want you can make
it more supreme right super God not just
God but God squared or something like
that that doesn't get you got existing
in reality as the conclusion of your
argument this does if you follow along
with an Psalms logic so there's a big
difference between these two ideas the
one of them is kind of a positive idea
isn't it and the other one is kind of a
negative idea it's more of a restriction
about ideas that's why it seems so
mysterious that's why when you tried to
wrap your head around it you struggle it
I do I've been researching this and
writing about a logical argument how
long now almost a decade as a matter of
fact I went to the first st. Anton
conference and presented on different
models of the ontological argument more
than ten years ago and I've been
thinking about it and actually writing a
book on it since that and I still don't
fully understand
logical argument because I can't fully
exhaust this idea any more than you can
there's something weird about this idea
something very different than say our
idea of a tangible object that we can
look at where your idea of who you are
as you know MS Engel you know or new
Santos or any anyone of you there's
something very different about those
kinds of ideas and this kind of idea so
we'll explore that a little bit more now
with all that in mind what's going out
of the pro slogan let's look at the
introduction to the probe the probe on
the Travis I touched on this a little
bit last class but again it's been a
week so you've probably forgotten most
of that the anthem says what am i doing
in this whole work not just in chapters
two through four of the whole work I had
another work beforehand called long ago
genome and in that work I was trying to
think about you know those be like and
if God exists and you know is jihad
three and one or just water you know all
these sorts of things and I have a whole
bunch of arguments and they seem to be
kind of jumbled together in one big heap
and I wanted to try to make it more
we're simple more straightforward and so
I try to boil it down to one single
argument and that argument would be
enough to prove itself and a whole bunch
of things what a dance some say as goal
was to do
one of the what do you want to do with
this argument what do you want to prove
yeah that's one really big thing so he
wants to prove that God exists and you
know we talked about this before are
there a lot of atheists of man Tom's
time in the whether the Christian world
or the Muslim world or you know pick
anywhere else in the world a lot so it's
kind of a strange thing to do but he
doesn't unless that's not all he's doing
know what else does he want to prove
what is he saying that texts not exist
something else about that yeah well
that's that's what he's gonna use as his
linchpin for that but he's not actually
gonna prove that he's gonna use that as
an assumption what is he saying that he
wants to prove some other attribute of
God besides existing
well what are other things that we say
about God people in our society it more
or less the same conception of God this
is an something
why do people go to church if you don't
go to church I'm sure you know some
people who go to church
what do they think they're doing there
in some of the gener at times people
went to church to hook up alright but
that's not usually what happens in
church these days you could make deals
and it's a good place to do business
well that's not really why most people
go to church either always that supposed
some people do I knew people go to
church and bother with all this God
stuff yeah say that three three other
sins okay what are sins
that's a theological concept what do you
mean what do you have in mind
okay very good so things that people
think are morally wrong I was actually
talking about this earlier today in
ethics class
Thomas Aquinas talks about sins in two
different ways you can think about them
as a moral philosopher and say sins are
those acts that are morally wrong where
you can think of them and theologically
and say sins or an axe God doesn't like
doesn't want you to do it remember we
talked about this with the Euthyphro
right piety is doing things God wants
you to do and not doing the things he
doesn't want so God is concerned with
goodness you think God is good generally
that's what people have thought right if
you start bringing in goodness yeah oh
start bringing in goodness let's say you
got God or a really good sub sandwich of
choice really good sub sandwiches really
good and you're hungry right really good
sub sandwich or eternal beatitude with
the creator of the universe which
depicts sandwich let's assume for the
moment to make this example work that
you picked God instead right
why what are you getting out of that you
know a lot of people's notions of heaven
when you look at them seem extremely
boring they're getting security
okay security that could so maybe
security is a the feeling of security is
a better good than for me a meatball
challenge that's my favorite so is there
anything else maybe in the picture I
mean actually you know if feeling of
security really matters to you and
believing in God makes you feel secure
that might get it good practical reason
to believe in God there there are some
arguments I don't think very good
arguments but there are some arguments
about gods
since that run along those closer lines
I don't teach them to you because I
don't consider them to be particularly
good arguments people do make them well
let me think about God in terms of
thought like different kinds of goods
remember we talked about different kinds
of goods back when we did Aristotle so
one of the things you guys considered
that some sandwich doesn't mean all that
same family okay security what do you
get out of family what woody what's not
everybody's family is a great experience
some people hate their family I'm not
one of them by the way I'm just telling
you I know some people do hate their
family ok so again it's it's really
security right it was loyalty throwing
in did you like your family you enjoy
being with them so there's a pleasure
that comes with that might be more
pleasant to go to a movie with one of
your family members that by yourself or
with some chance acquaintance so family
food security what else do you guys
validate what what makes you tick what
are you
silence back what are you guys looking
for yet all sorts of things when we talk
about Aristotle pleasure
yeah various pleasures I mean there are
some really gripped great pleasures out
there you haven't experienced a lot of
pleasure yet you're get a lot of stuff
in store for you because you know
there's so many different things that
are pleasant that you can enjoy some of
them take a little bit of refinement you
gotta you know try to educate yourself
and like I'm not a good wine drinker
because I'm too lazy to educate my
palate to do to really be able to
appreciate a wine you know I know what
I'd like to drink and that's it
you know there's ones for the table
there's slightly more refined ones for
for dessert that's about it for me but I
know some people who act as a benefit to
have a friend who teaches students how
to appreciate wine over at the culinary
and I sanded on this class I learned
what one would do if you truly
appreciated one that takes a lot of work
one reason I'm not planning on following
up on that but you know there's
pleasures of mind when you truly
understand Aristotle Doran some or
really any of the other subject matters
that you guys are studying that you're
in a major there's a great pleasure that
comes with that something going beyond
pleasure though - yeah I think for
instance criminal justice I know you're
studying criminal justice let's assume
that you end up becoming a case manager
or something like that there's a lot of
different ways you could
that's what it means you're going to be
writing reports maybe making decisions
about people's watch should this person
will go back to prison should this
person be released and be under
surveillance should this person does
this person deserve to not be under
surveillance let's say you actually get
this sort of support that you're
supposed to have which often doesn't pan
out and you make good decisions about
that you will feel pleasure and doing
your job well
you'll feel pleasure and doing the sort
of activity that you've trained for but
you'll feel sort of satisfaction that
goes beyond that won't you that's a good
thing that's something I desire for all
of you and anybody who wishes you well
should you desire that you should push
that for each other right it's a good
thing for you to desire that for other
people now let's think about God if
there really is such a thing as God
where would he fit in with all these
goodnesses down the bottom high up what
do you think
why do people go off in the desert and
become monks they just like getting tan
it's quiet out there you can give just
go to another town nobody knows you you
want to be alone to worship God yeah so
those guys at least so I don't remember
canceling is one of those guys that God
is the greatest
and that which makes all the other goods
good not everybody believes in this
right I mean obviously if you don't
believe there's God you're not going to
think that that God is the good that
makes all other goods what they are you
never get off the ground I mean you
could actually be an atheist and say
yeah well if there was a God he or she
or it would be ultimately good but there
isn't any such thing so we know if to
worry about or you might be an atheist
and saying you know if there's going to
be a god I expect that God to be so good
that there wouldn't be any evil this is
actually one of the arguments against
God's existence that people make all the
argument from evil then he had some
because of another thing so we can't
we're gonna prove that God exists we're
gonna prove that God is good and then
what else are we gonna this is kind of a
trick question does anyone remember what
he says he says and everything else that
we believe about God so you got this
kind of let's call it the physical John
together they're all familiar with the
junkyard ocean you guys have a junk
drawer and at home you know what I mean
when I say too dumb to her you might
call it something else
the magnetic should be a drawer for you
it could be like you know some sort of
storage thing what am I talking about I
said junk drawer
do you Denny do you have any something
like that at home yeah so what what's it
what are you do with a junk drawer yeah
like you know you don't know where the
tape goes throw it in the junk drawer
got a couple of screws left over throw
them in the junk drawer pretty soon that
junk drawer it's pretty full of of stuff
then maybe you need a bigger junk drawer
right so when we talk about the
miscellaneous you know just throw
everything else well that's what we mean
what else do people believe about God or
a say about God you know but I don't
have thinking things mind like he's got
a long beard that's not a very
interesting doesn't call property yeah
what are you suggesting okay what are
the can things people do say about gas
typically whether you believe that
they've made a candy they say oh what a
sweet Katya is ok so they exalted
there's that notion of height being
greater you know there's there's a lot
of ways to to phrase that what else goes
along with that usually how much we know
let me put a feel like this this is a
leading question how does God like Santa
Claus and the notions christmas is
coming up I think he sees you when
you're sleeping it doubles when you're
awake he has power well that's that's up
Nippon tents we usually say that God is
all-powerful right that's fine so it
says about about God yeah he's exactly a
dance mom says that because that's the
sort of thing that that Christians and
Jews and Muslims have said about God
throughout the ages and they probably
will be proud
I was thinking action more of a missions
right Santa Claus is kind of up Nishant
isn't he so you do initially Bing he
knows when you're awake which is a
little bit creepy he knows if you've
been bad or good so you better be good
the way the song goes for goodness sake
because if you don't that he will get
you you know Santa Claus doesn't really
get you of any major sense back it back
in my childhood I actually did get coal
in my stocking some years it was
charcoal no because they wanted to be
able to you know send me a message shape
up
now the notion of God is being on the
wagons that God could actually look at
the both every human heart know what's
going on you know if a butterfly dies
over on the other side of the world God
know about that's omniscience
what are other things people say about
God all powerful ignitions good anything
else
can God do bad stuff
accordin some he or she failed yeah it
was I mean to most the most Christians
think that God can do bad things you
know the answer I was pretty typical in
this respect
well he doesn't come out and say it was
me that's all right that's all right
sort of interpretation of that and yeah
I mean this is actually a problem
because there are other other verses
where it says like I create good and
evil you know like an exam but typically
Jews Christian will bless you thank you
well we'll try to hire you away
something like that well the grand
scheme of things it's it's the best
thing there there's there there are some
real legitimate philosophical problems
there that's one thing we're not
unfortunately I'm going to have that
much trying to explore for the problem
of people you know if God is so good
where all this evil come from but in
general people think of God as
somebody's not being able to do certain
things of course it wouldn't be god I
think like st. Augustine says well do
you think God is going to lie to you you
got a different conception in mind than
that of God you're thinking of something
different thank God but then it sounds
like God doesn't have a power that's
sounds like God's not omnipotent because
to be an impotent means what what is
Omni people back here
Latin prefixes alright
potent powerful so God leads God is an
infants and he should be able to do
everything right
that's so there's a paradox there then
we're going to look at that paradox in a
couple minutes I want to look at a few
other paradoxes too one of the things
that anseup says about God is that God
is merciful where is he getting this the
Bible right looks like what God being a
merciful God and all that but they also
talk about God as being a just God
now what do you know about merciful
people what do what are they inclined to
do forget exactly so and when do you
forgive people do you just go down the
street I forgive you I do I forget to
spreading forgiveness all around who do
you forgive people who done you wrong
yeah so if God is merciful that means
that he left some people off the hook
what does it mean to be just think back
to your Plato and a little bit of
Aristotle that we read what does justice
mean not the interest of the stronger
actor that was just for some ACCA's yeah
treat people according to give them what
they deserve right now if I'm a bad guy
and I've hurt you what do I deserve
tonight deserve mercy at all
I deserve that you've hurt me in return
or do something to me a punishment so if
God is both just and merciful then if
somebody like me
lifetime should he do both at once can
he do both at once can he be both just
and treating me the way I deserve to be
treated and yet also sort of let me have
the benefit of the doubt or another
chance can you do them that seems like
like oh that's kind of tradition there
doesn't that's a problem that's one
we're not actually going to explore I'm
going to put some stuff in either if
you're really interested in that cuz
I've done some writing on that as a
matter of fact my first article on the
end song that was ever published was
about God's justice of God's mercy and
how could they actually be reconciled
and there's some gyrations required for
that can you think of any other sort of
problems with this notion of God and all
this is we're going to throw everything
in or going to prove all this stuff
anything else come to mind some some
contradictions some paradoxus things
that bother you they don't necessarily
have to be an insolence text you know
because Anselm if he were here he would
try to you know address any sort of
objections people yeah let me say yeah
that that sounds like a real issue I'd
better think about that where other
problems that that come up with the idea
of God you're running to from time to
time
talk about reconciling goodness and evil
in the world power and not being able to
do certain things
mercy and justice anything else you can
think about that didn't make XP like
somebody tried to try to tell you God is
this and God is this at the same time
really that doesn't make any sense I
just take it on faith is there anything
like that in your experience
so maybe am some talked about it how
about like God is everywhere really I
mean like in my coffee cup or in my
heart in your heart in the desk all
around us how come I don't see in then
Anselm actually talks about that doesn't
mean in chapters 14 and 15 and 16 let's
look at the the the section where he
actually does treat one of these things
the issue about power and not being able
to do certain things so
and we'd have to stick necessarily to an
Ansel talks about what's sort of like
the pretend we're making a Family Guy
episode or what are what other cartoons
you get watch these kind of you know
funny cartoons where you don't watch
other cartoons like Simpsons or family
gonna Robot Chicken or any lesser things
you know they kind of make funny God
sometimes soft Park South Park is pretty
good with that how what did you watch
those kind of shows only a few then we
have to put ourselves in some other I
don't I don't know exactly what I would
use to it to as an example for you but
let's think about this way what are some
things you think God shouldn't be able
to do if he's gonna be God or it's gonna
be God how are you
what are some ideas they have about that
doesn't matter how crazy it sounds here
or even perhaps silly
you're gonna explore it what ideas what
shouldn't get what what are the things
that gasp shouldn't be able to do and
still be got yeah that's an interesting
like maybe like yeah this one actually
that the Ansel talks about god of this
this point but in other words take away
pretty well that's a good one we'll
explore that let's get some other ones
that's him
I mean the old medieval one is a good
God create a stone so happy he couldn't
lift it you know well you know either
way that's a problem you can't create
that stone it sounds like you can't do
everything and if you come there and sit
on so heavy you can't lift that sounds
like a problem to well let's think about
some other folks put aside the notion
that Christians have that God became
incarnate
Kanade poems here that would be a
problem right so very trivial thing
well what are other things that given
the notion of God that we tend to work
with in this society God might not be
able to do can't walk around on earth
okay yeah I live in this notion that you
know the Christians have that Jesus was
incarnate God at one time there's
however you want to frame it you can't I
mean we can't walk around physically on
earth or yeah we don't see God okay so
let's say that he you know and this is
kind of an interesting one because if
you think about the Bible in the very
first book it treats God and very
anthropomorphic terms and in terms very
much like a human being so talks about
God walking around in the garden and
saying hey where are you which doesn't
sound like a you know the kind of thing
that would be admissions maybe that's a
problem maybe maybe could God be
confused if he's God
it's got
another one that's that a lot of the
people are puzzled about but God make
things different than they are so
somewhere along the line I used to
actually be a really good physical shape
when I was her age I was about a hundred
and ninety pounds and Justin getting all
prime physical condition who said I was
in the Army I used to do a 5-mile run
but I was a smoker back then and I would
I was in such good shape
I could actually run and smoke at the
same time it didn't bother me now of
course you know the more you do that
pretty soon you could camera and I'll
get the same thing let's say you know
God says I'm not really happy with the
way things turned out for you Greg
Sadler you let yourself go I'm going to
go and change the past and this would be
sort of like mr. Ross idea about God
changing your mind or determining you
accepting going in the past and so god
interferes with my free will and says
okay you're not going to stop working
out and you're not going to eat whatever
you want for the next ten years and then
suddenly here I am and I'm 40 pounds
lighter and a good portion of that is it
is you know big muscle when I'm up in
front of class teaching look very
different right maybe I'm not wearing a
sweater I'm wearing a very neatly
tailored European suit and I look final
and all these sorts of things could God
do that sort of thing could he go in and
tinker with the path
to make the past no longer be what it
was so that the president would turn off
differently it sort of like these sci-fi
things where if somebody goes back in
time yeah shouldn't even gotten it right
in the first place was so colorful oh
there's a problem that there isn't there
which more omniscient we're all good
right each one of these would seem to be
like a restriction on God being
all-powerful wouldn't it God can't do
these things it's actually in this case
even if God can do it it seems like it's
a problem but now that's getting us
towards the solution other things that
they'll bring out physically God why
could God do bad things deliberately now
think about what happens with some of
these things and what's why or being
confused is being confused a good thing
okay there's a there's effects there's
emotional effects I feel that too as a
matter of fact the worst thing is when
you have two people that are talking to
each other and they're both confused and
then they get frustrated with each other
and they're arguing and then they start
saying well I think the arguments about
this now they're just as though it's
about this then it just escalates right
but then let's put that aside let's put
the emotional stuff aside being confused
is not a good thing and the be confused
means in some way not actually having a
power it means something else having
power over you doesn't it something else
being more powerful than you so it's not
really to be confused is not a state of
power
what about line
people i well think about our experience
i know i lie which i have done when i
feel too uncomfortable telling the truth
because i would be too embarrassed to
tell the truth try to think about I
think I have lied at some points in time
just to like you know given the adage
over somebody else especially in
argument I used to be a really vicious
are quite neat people other other
graduate students and I would say that I
knew something that I didn't actually
know what was driving the urge to beat
somebody else what else do people lie
near experience why have people lied to
you to get away with things right now
what was going on in those people who
wanted to get away with things who they
just you know perfectly fine and they
just chose to lie get away with
something or was there something going
on with them yeah they could be they're
afraid of punishment yeah that that's a
prime one that often leads to more lies
yeah we are I think that they're kicking
me too - we want things to be both ways
for us of the exceptions - to the rule
so now you can pick up some really
different who are you say got themselves
into a situation that they can get out
of a flight line there you go yeah
that's that's similar to the other ones
that we've brought up now notice what
all of these have in common
again it looks like lying is the
exercise of a power doesn't but it's
really something that you do when
something else has power over you
whether it's embarrassment why do people
want to have their cake and eat it too
what's going on yeah they're being
selfish they're being driven by their
own selfish desires are giving in to a
worse part of themselves they're not
giving in to their better part you know
we generally don't actually give in to
our better parts we get into our worst
parts and sometimes we obey our better
parts doing and if that's the case is
that really the exercise of a power or
is that being less powerful if you lie
or cheat or steal or you know kill
people that discriminately or do these
things that we're not supposed to do
you're not doing them generally because
you feel like you're so powerful and you
can do anything you want you're doing
them because something else is
constraining you because you feel the
power less and this is one way to try to
get some of that power back so if God
were to be able to why God would in fact
be less than what God is to be am nipa
Tain's would actually mean that you
couldn't lie because to be able to lie
means something being able to have
something else over you
Cole Monsieur take a war they're
probably not quite the same thing as
lying if God had a physical body
look let's spaghetti let's put aside
this troublesome case of this this Jesus
Christ guy all right let's just take a
minute ins omniscient creator of the
universe sort of idea that people have
this is what this was a problem that a
lot of people had with Christianity when
I first came up so wait a minute your
God got nailed on a cross what the hell
kind of God is that do you mean you've
walked around and he didn't hang out
with the rich of the mighty but he hung
out with a bunch of dirty fishermen and
riffraff what are you talking about that
was that was one of the problems that a
lot of people yeah didn't the early
Roman Empire but a late woman up there
early Christian era with Christianity
because it seemed like that doesn't some
much like a divine figure at all so I
was like the divine should be in a very
exalted faith of God has a body it
should be like a super body right God
would have to be super attractive and a
great physical shape have any group ever
looked at the the image that they they
came up the National Geographic came up
with this composite image of what what
Christ probably would look like doesn't
look like the picture that we have in
all these churches that kind of squat
those kinda looks a little bit like
Socrates
would it be a power to be able to to
have physical form to be constrained
physical form well this is a good
question we can make it very prosaic all
of you in the class we have long hair
okay
you're sort of right on the verge of
long and short but you've probably kept
longer here at one time right why is
long here Canada pain what do you have
to what do you dislike about having long
hair what what bothers you about it
sometimes gets tangled right what else
yeah this way often often some of you
actually have you here
hi dad what else yeah conditioner in it
wash it the ends get split and you gotta
go to the hair and hair cutter
hairdresser get a cut you know and it
doesn't look exactly the way that you
wanted to and I would it gets hot you
know summertime long hair gets kind of
hot
all right so it's nice to shave it so
you know if God could walk around and
have hair and stuff like that would that
really be to be powerful what do you
think got it a physical body do not
really be taking on powers what goes
wrong with your body prime example right
there right what's wrong what's going on
with your body that makes you feel not
so hot right now
coughing because you are thank God in a
physical body God can presumably get
sick is getting sick the example of
actually having power it's something
else having power over you so again with
all these example what does the answer
saying we don't really think of power
the right way we think of the power as
being able to do anything but there's a
lot of things that if you could do it
would really mean another thing having
power over you you know like we've used
this example before and he wanted you to
get addicted to heroin if you wanted to
I could - isn't that really a power you
know I mean the junk you might think to
themselves yeah on top of the world
while they're high but that that desire
has a is a control over them so this is
how an saw reconciles these sorts of
things he does a similar thing with with
mercy and justice he does another
similar thing with what you know how can
God actually know everything and you
know certain sense see everything that
he does they have my balls he doesn't
see physical things the way we do remain
- yes right immense heads in this
classroom one is black and has a Yankee
is staying on it one is blue and is that
Texas and has Texas Rangers has the
Texas Rangers thank God does God
actually know these hats and that way
the way I do seeing things with my eyes
maybe that doesn't make sense to think
about it that way
but if if that's the case maybe God
doesn't know everything and sometimes
nothing has an answer for that one we
don't we're not going to go into that
one but I just want us to a gesture
towards it let's move now to that all
this talk about white and you know the
inaccessible light in which God dwells
because that's where Anselm is good
movie and father and you notice if you
read through those passages it doesn't
read like somebody who has solved every
single problem it reads like somebody
who thinks that he's learned some things
about God by using that notion of that
there's nothing
go outside well that must mean this must
be yeah and he thought his way through
some problems but he still says and in
very English terms why is it God if I
know this stuff about you that I don't
sense your presence
this is a holy guy who the guy who was
living his life in prayer who from you
know the biography that we had one turn
looks like a pretty decent human being
and yet he doesn't feel like he actually
grasps God says I know by you know all
these arguments that I put together that
you worked everywhere that you made me
that you know you're all good you're all
going you're all powerful you have all
these attributes
why don't I sense them if you're
everywhere why don't I see you well
there could be two ways to go with that
right well let's think about for common
sensical thing you know we'll take out
of the picture let's use this coffee cup
what could the coffee cup could exist in
you're not see right how could come to
Daddy
we get heightened over here now you
can't see it but let's say the coffee
cup is out some of you are seeing it
right now some of you aren't why because
some of you did what this is this kind a
good example actually
yeah some of you are looking right at it
and some of you are looking at your most
of your computer screens you're looking
at something else but you can also turn
around again look at the code you could
get a willfully that's again there are
other things that could interfere with
you see this is a physical object right
what else could interfere to you seeing
this coffee cup oh yeah you could be
blocked by somebody else right so much
if you're sitting in the back shorter
than some of the other women sitting in
front of you but else somebody could
turn out the lights and then maybe we
can do we don't see anything
or it could be foggy in here or you
could be drunk you could get so drunk
you can actually focus your eyes there's
all sorts of possibilities and that's
just talking about a coffee cup which is
a physical object that you actually do
sense now if we're thinking about a
human being human know her and then God
what is know some of those things could
come up as well you know the the example
of looking away right maybe some people
don't know anything about God because
they look at other stuff and stuff right
that that doesn't seem that that
difficult maybe you actually when you
got your idea of God you didn't get the
right idea if you got the idea of God as
just being this guy up in the sky
somewhere who's going to
you know like you know be super Santa
Claus and punish you with your naughty
which was you know what some people tell
in Sunday school or CCD that's the the
image certainly not see him as I got
when I was a kid and went to CCD they
happen to me the other contradicted
contradictory thing God doesn't love and
just wants you to be nice to each other
it's just kind of a warm fuzzy maybe
those aren't actually maybe that's some
other so that you're looking at these
other ideas you're not going to see the
the actual reality if there is one right
this is all making the assumption there
is God could anything else be screwing
this up I mean you could actually
lectern deliberately away learn anything
about any of this stuff sorta stuff this
is all garbage that was certainly keep
you from being able to know anything
about God wouldn't would there be
anything that's like equivalent to being
blind drunk yes being ignorant yeah then
maybe you know yeah you resting I came
from the Midwest in the Midwest I think
it's a lot like the the area that you
guys grew up in for the most part where
all of you whether you're religious or
not you know people who are religious
right everyone in here know some people
who are religious and other people who
are you know there's some people who are
religious that are real serious about it
there they seem to be you know track
with and there's other people who seem
to be real religious and it's kind of
for show right and then there are some
people who are not religious and maybe
if they have some religion they'd be
better people and there's other people
who are religious and they're pretty
good people right so you've got a wide
range of experience in friend who is
from California and he California is a
very secular area in some parts of it
and we would talk about religion and he
have nothing to pin these ideas on
because the culture that it grew up in
didn't have any religious people period
or if it did you just didn't really have
any contact yeah so when it came to
talking about these ideas he had a very
very difficult time figuring out how
somebody could possibly be interested in
this or you know take this stuff serious
whereas all of you can can even if you
don't you know you think it's all the
gas you can still understand how
somebody could take it seriously right
both of you who are religious I think
all of you can sort of figure out why
somebody also might have problems with
the religion right you're you're sort of
in the middle zone but probably there's
an equivalent where everybody in the
society is so hyper religious that you
can't possibly relate to anybody in the
middle zone or the other zone sort of
like religious brewing on that secular
thing he didn't have anything when it
came to this stuff so certain kind of
ignorance God really is everywhere then
why does everybody think that's a good
question it doesn't make sense yeah
Anselm could could give a response of it
let me let me go along with those
responses in the gifts I think that will
sort of the line so when he's trying to
think of his own example again we've got
this guy who's a monkey but I'm you know
trying to get close to God for a long
time so if he can't get close to God you
know what's the chance of course slobs
like us right well what do you sweat he
notices is it could be they suggest this
ability that God is sort of like the Sun
you can see things in sunlight pretty
well can't you can you look straight at
the Sun let's see what it looks like
maybe for an instant well then what
happens to your eyes don't do this by
the way there are some people who like
willfully look at the Sun for like five
ten minutes at a time but they haven't
seemed to do that burn your eyeballs
actually the light going in burns the
back of your eyes maybe God is so
powerful we have those Anselm's idea
maybe God is so powerful so you know
incredible includes so much that the
human mind is not able to take in all of
that the atom can only take in a portion
just a tiny sliver of what it is that
God is not the reality itself that's
what he's suggesting right in those
chapters you say god you're maybe it's
not just at my eyes the halls are
darkened maybe that you're so bright
that I can't take it in you've all been
blinded before right somebody flashed a
camera in your face
or you got too close to sparklers that
fourth of July or anything like that and
then you can't release you can't make
things out does that mean that the
things aren't there just means you can't
see them as well or you bought a
flashlight your face at night
hopefully not from
their face because you're being pulled
over or something like that